what up space fam goes in here from
anime up we're back at it again with
another attack on titan video
for this video i thought it would be a
lot of fun to break down the final
season opening of the attack on time
anime so we can discuss all the
references and the meaning
the lyrics are very telling and
applicable too and we may even have
clues for stuff that's yet to happen in
the manga in here so i'm
very psyched to get into it if you also
want to see me do this kind of video for
the closing song of the final season
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is critical
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future attack on titan videos and
while you wait for the next aot video to
drop feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers all the ackermans and their
powers
the titans ranked for weakest the
strongest and much more linked to that
is in the description
obviously i will be using manga
information to help explain the final
season opening visuals
and song because it wouldn't be any fun
otherwise
so if you aren't caught up with the
manga and don't want to know any
specifics about what will happen
this is your obligatory spoiler warning
now without further ado let's jump into
the breakdown
let's now look at the final season
opening song it's called my war
obviously war has been a focus
throughout attack on titan specifically
the words my war
seem like they could be coming from
aaron to me as he's the one who carries
out his own war
separate from the survey corps in this
season he decides to go alone to marley
to declare war with the world then he
breaks out of jail on parodies island
and after he unlocks the founding titan
and the rumbling
he proceeds to destroy most of the world
aside from paradise island
and he does this against the wishes of
everyone including his formerly closest
friends armin and mikasa
although everyone is fighting their war
almost everyone has
other people on their side in fact
marlei forces and the survey corps start
working together in an attempt to stop
aaron's final skeletal titan form while
aaron wages his war alone this leads us
well to the opening lyrics la vida sola
vivivaras i used google translate and
asked spanish speakers to translate for
me into english
and the translation i got was life alone
you will live
almost everything that applies here to
aaron can potentially be said about emir
fritz as well
the first and founding titan who is now
supporting aaron and allowing him to
carry out his war
both of them have lived a lonely life
emir fritz after she died
lived alone in the unknown land a
parallel world where you can see the
paths that connect all
eldians she continued to be a slave to
the royal family following their command
so that people like zeke
eventually came to view her as nothing
but a mindless slave
they failed to notice that she was and
still is a human being
it's not like she just spent 2 000 years
in this world
which is about how much time passed
chronologically since her death no
i'd argue she spent much more time than
that
time works differently in this place and
every time a shifter transforms or a
titan is formed or regenerates instantly
in the real world it's a result of emir
fritz slowly molding the titan body out
of sand
in this parallel world think about it
she had to mold
all of those tens of millions of
colossal titans
that must have felt like an eternity
hers might just be the loneliest
existence in all of anime and the lyrics
life alone you will live can obviously
also apply to aaron who has become
completely separated from the world and
all of his old friends like armin and
mikasa
even though he's carrying out his war
for the people who born raised him aka
for the people of paradise island which
include his friends
in order to do that he had to separate
himself from them because they would
never approve of his methods
ironically him wanting to protect his
friends from the world
ended up meaning he could no longer
remain their friends at least not in the
same way as before
animak my brother and the other half of
anime uproar
speaks some spanish and also suggested
the lyrics might read
the life i alone saw you will live which
would be an interesting reference to the
attack titan's ability to see the future
as well
since aaron can use his titan powers to
see future memories
it is possible that he alone saw that
through his bloody methods
he could ensure a safe and peaceful life
for arm and mikasa again it will be very
interesting as the last chapters of
attack on titan come out
to see how these future memories may
come into play in the story and keep in
mind while i give different
interpretations
that when analyzing poetry and songs a
line doesn't have to mean one thing
it can mean multiple things at the same
time so one interpretation does not
necessarily cancel out another rather
they build on each other but for now
let's jump to the visuals
the opening starts in the clouds a
reference to the importance of the sky
and flying in this season before falco
became a flying titan
there was talk about a titan that could
fly in the marlene military they thought
such a titan would be very useful in
modern warfare
where most of the important future
battles will be decided in the sky
obviously we know from our perspective
that they're right in their prediction
how useful will grounded titans be when
you can just drop
a nuclear bomb on them from a plane
overhead and most titans wouldn't be
able to reach a plane
if it's flying high enough so the sky
represents the future of warfare but it
also represents freedom
falco whose name is associated with
birds reaches out his hand in the
direction of a bird at the beginning of
the season
he's on a battlefield and he says the
birds should use its wings to fly
somewhere far away from this war
birds and flight have long represented
freedom for humans over the centuries
probably even more so when we were
completely grounded and didn't have
aircrafts the importance of the sky and
flight becomes even more important when
aaron unleashes the rumbling which
flattens the earth the only way to avoid
being flattened by them
is to take to the skies and fly over
them falco's flying titan comes in very
handy when he rescues mikasa
reiner and the others from aaron's
skeletal titan though he does bring him
back on the titan soon enough
it's the only titan that could actually
maneuver so well around aaron's giant
titan
and all those surrounding colossal
titans so the importance of the sky and
flying through it
should be clear enough we then see more
modern landscapes
like marlene territory go up in
explosions and flames
we get plenty scenes of war we see ships
getting taken down
a scene reminiscent of when the beast
titan destroys ships with his throwing
ability
at fort slava we see soldiers firing
modern weapons
we see a giant nuclear looking explosion
after a seeming titan transformation
this is of course a reference to armin's
colossal titan
and its explosion ability that can cause
massive damage
we see a soldier using a flamethrower
too all of these scenes fit the war
title well
and most of the soldiers i'd guess are
marlene's we see birds falling
possibly to their death representing
perhaps loss of freedom and the death of
innocent people
even the once open and free skies have
become a battlefield
again all the bird imagery also nods
towards falco
and his flying titan transformation
falco and the flying titan based on the
intro
and outro are going to be of top
importance
in this season and the finale from the
looks of it the lyrics now continue in
english
using different languages also nods
towards how this final season will
transcend nations and cultures
after all aaron does attack the entire
world there are screams of justice in
the background
and that's what everyone is searching
for including aaron in his own way
he wants revenge for what the marlenes
took from him but more importantly he
also wants justice for his people
wanting them to be able to live life in
peace without having to be viewed as
devils that need to be eradicated
obviously everyone is crying out for
justice including armin reiner gabby and
the others but it looks different for
everyone you ask
the lyrics then go and i quote let's
start a new life from the darkness
until the light reveals the end end
quote this
is the path that aaron seems to have
chosen in order to start a new life in
order to find the light
he has committed to going through the
darkness in a machiavellian
sense the end he seeks for his friends
and people
justifies the horrible means he's using
to make it a reality
in his view he's destroying this world
so a new better one can emerge for his
people
one without hatred fighting and war
we'll see how the series ends but what
is interesting is how king carl fritz
managed to turn back time
technologically speaking within the
walls while technology advanced outside
the walls
they went back to quote unquote simpler
times within the walls
if aaron does destroy the entire world
and humanity has to start over
it is possible that weapons of war will
cease to develop or at least
cease to develop at the same pace
because right now they are definitely on
track to create nuclear bombs and
weapons that can blow up the world
perhaps aaron foresaw an atomic bomb
being dropped on paradise island and
this is why he decided to destroy the
rest of the world and its technology
we don't know for sure but it's possible
that aaron like carl
plans to return the humanity that
remains to a simpler less
technologically dangerous time
except he'll do it for the entire
remaining world rather than for one
isolated area the lyrics continue and i
quote sinister
faces growing curses this is my last war
end quote to me these sinister faces
could refer to the way marleians look at
eldians while they subjected them
and mistreated them the growing curses
could refer to the unending and growing
cycle of hatred and revenge between
different nations like marlei and eldia
and individuals
the same cycle of revenge and hatred
that aaron is trying to put a stop to
once and for all this is my last war
seems to be something aaron would say
he doesn't plan for there to be wars
after this because he'll completely wipe
out one side so the cycle of hatred and
revenge
ends or he'll die trying either way it
will be his last war
of course another theory is that aaron
plans to be killed by the survey corps
and other eldians so that the world will
see that they are heroes rather than
devils and not want to kill them anymore
although it is possible if this was
aaron's plan
he probably didn't have to kill as many
people as he already did but even if
aaron pulls a zero requiem it'll still
be his last war i for one definitely
think that aaron's ready to die
as soon as he finishes carrying out his
plan we then see visuals of merlan
soldiers marching in unison and we all
know what this is reminiscent of
the point that's emphasized with scenes
like this is that marlei
as a nation is not just the victim as
one marlene mentions
their actions created the devil that is
aaron jaeger
that being said though there are
innocent marlene people including
children
who did nothing wrong and now they are
paying for the sins of their parents
this is the darkness that was mentioned
earlier aaron knows this is horrible but
he's willing to do the darkest things to
bring his gold to light
the lyrics continue and i quote angels
playing disguise with devil's faces
end quote you might argue that aaron or
emir fritz
are the angels playing disguise with
devil's faces since the titan faces
are sort of like devil's faces emir
fritz was also called a goddess and
aaron is acting like the devil
to bring about a paradise for others to
protect the people he cares about but
for me this more so refers to the
aldians and people from parodies
like armin reiner annie and mikasa who
are trying to stop aaron from destroying
the world marlene's in the rest of the
world view aldians as devils and thus
they have devil's faces
and yet there are angels in their
actions working to save the people that
want them dead
mikasa even appeared to have wings at
one point when the flying titan appeared
behind her in the manga
probably the closest we get to an
angelic image
visually we see an aircraft sharing the
sky with a bird
again emphasizing the growing importance
of the skies
and how they're no longer human free and
safe we see statues explode including
statues of survey corps members with
their vertical maneuvering gear on
suggesting we're going to have heavy
losses on all sides
another lyric reads and i quote children
cling to their coins squeezing out their
wisdom end quote
and it's hard to even hear all the
lyrics in this song
i definitely didn't know what was going
on until i looked them up and that
further reflects the chaos and competing
voices in this season the lyric about
the children
clearly makes me think about aaron and
his colossal titans trampling them
children are victims of this war
too and keep in mind reiner annie
bertolt and marcel were kids when they
invaded parodies island initially
then gabby and falco as children entered
wars too
although wisdom has been squeezed out
aka nothing makes sense anymore
it reminds me of what harper lee said
about the war novel catch-22
she said it is the only war novel she's
ever read that makes any sense
the funny thing is catch 22 doesn't make
any sense
nothing that happens in it is rational
lee said that because
if a war novel does make sense it
actually doesn't make sense because
war doesn't make sense similarly attack
on titan portrays the often senseless
aspects of war the wise thing to do
would have been for aldian's marlenes
and the whole world to treat each other
with respect
the way they'd want to be treated that's
the golden rule from like every religion
and culture
treat others the way you want to be
treated if you don't want to get
subjugated by others don't subjugate
them
if you don't want to be treated unfairly
don't treat others unfairly if you don't
want others creating weapons of mass
destruction
don't create weapons of mass destruction
if everyone followed the golden rule
a lasting paradise could be possible
of course this rule is much easier said
than followed
and as in real life human fear hatred
thirst for revenge clouds people's
judgments and so the only way aaron can
see
to solve the problem now is to do
something as crazy as flattening the
world with colossal titans
we keep seeing explosion after explosion
foreshadowing the utter destruction
we're going to see this season it is
practically the end of the world or the
apocalypse that takes place
we continuously see signs of humanity
like towers and buildings being blown
away
suggesting that what remains of humanity
will have to start from scratch
the following lyrics destruction and
regeneration
point to that too aaron hopes that
through this destruction
through this hell a new paradise can
emerge there's a winston churchill quote
that goes like this
if you're moving through hell keep going
that quote seems to embody aaron the
attack titan
and the idea of moving forward no matter
how bad it gets
another lyric goes you are the real
enemy
another quote that means something
completely different depending on who's
saying it for aaron the people that want
to wipe his people out are the enemy for
the world aaron is the enemy the devil
who's come to destroy them the question
is who
is the real enemy and many people have
even said that aaron our protagonist
has become the villain or enemy an
attack on titan and we're forced to ask
who is the real enemy marlei
aaron or you aka us meaning humanity
we've seen throughout history that
ordinary humans have been capable of
truly evil things and it makes me wonder
if this you are the real
enemy line can be said from the
perspective of the spine-like creature
that gave a mere titan powers in the
first place
this is an out-there theory but what if
this centipede-like creature represented
the natural world
and its goal was to wipe out humanity or
at least significantly lower the
population
because people continued to wage war
destroy and pollute
to the detriment of plants and animals
as we saw when the birds were falling
from the sky
earlier during this opening it did cross
my mind that the devil of the earth
which
could be the spine-like creature was
actually a manifestation of the earth's
will
that's finally turned against humans the
fact that mindless titans clearly get
energy from the sun
like plants and can manifest animal
qualities like the beast titan
does make you think but anyways we jump
to lyrics of war
my war and then the word monster is
repeated
these words are sung while we see rain
falling on piles and piles of bodies
clearly this seems like the people aaron
trampled using the rumbling it's a nod
to his eventual actions
and it's crazy to think that our
protagonists would be capable of doing
something so horrific
and of course then it zooms into the
attack titan statue with other titans
attached to it seemingly following him
or
trying to catch him and the words
monster are repeated
suggesting to the viewers that aaron is
the monster or at least he is from many
people's perspectives
and even from the world's perspective
the statue looks like the titan
continues to move forward while stepping
over mountains of corpses
however it is a statue meaning it no
longer has
life so this can be read as after aaron
finishes with the rumbling
he'll cease to live maybe there was some
sort of weapon that could stop him
or maybe he just chose to use the power
of the titans to turn himself into a
statue
after he fulfilled the mission we
already know that the fanning titan can
alter the composition
of any aldian's body any way it sees fit
we can't know for sure until the final
chapters drop but it seems clear that
this is a post-apocalyptic world we're
being shown
but also it seems to be a post-titan
world my guess would be that aaron will
let the other titan shifters like armin
live but he may change their body
composition
and make it so they can no longer turn
into titans as a result
emir's curse would be suspended too and
after helping to create a safer world
for the people of parodies island in a
world where titans are relics of the
past aaron will meet his end one way or
another
the remaining people will have a chance
to start over and get it right this time
around
although you'll never be able to
guarantee whether they'll get it right
or not
but honestly attack on titan has
surprised me many times so you can't 100
predict the end even though it's
tempting to try when we get extras like
the opening of the final season that's
one of the reasons that takataine stays
so interesting and that is it for this
one let me know if you had any
interesting interpretations that i
didn't cover
if you want to see another analysis this
time of the ending credits
make sure to warhammer smash that like
button if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is critical
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future attack on titan videos and
while you wait for the next aot video to
drop
feel free to check out my growing attack
on time playlist where we got videos
about all the titan shifters and their
powers the acronyms and their powers the
titans rank from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one dear patrons the ones
who stand top all clans in grata the
world acquire respect pate heffa
liam thompson al-jatal dr cortman
johnny boy draws emperor otaku spidey
life tinel baked buddhist and tungsten
tarkis
and are pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsuki joe stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fondrethu and aora alicia
actor bonnie parks hinokami and water
the red-haired raven joanne garcia jack
watches anime fat boy games deadly saint
matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so you can support
work on that way if you prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you